breaking news meine damen und herren
denn es gibt eine bombendrohung gegen
einen krankenhaus in bremerhaven und
unser reporter den wir gerade schon
gesehen haben gerd schröder ist dort
live vor ort gerät
ja es gab ja eine bombendrohung auf das
krankenhaus bremer haften mitte mitte
und ja dieses dieses krankenhaus ist
hier ziemlich stadtnah und hier sind
also jetzt alle rettungskräfte
angefordert worden weil unklar ist ob
teilbereiche des krankenhauses hier
evakuiert werden müssen es sind
rettungskräfte aus der ganzen region
zusammengezogen worden schnelle
einsatzgruppe nennt sich dass das sind
auch viele freiwillige kräfte mit
rettungswagen vom roten kreuz und die
haben sich jetzt hier bereits
bereitgestellt der bereich am
krankenhaus selber ist weiträumig
abgesperrt die polizei ist jetzt am
krankenhaus um dort auch erste
durchsuchungsmaßnahmen stattfinden zu
lassen und dann wird sich entscheiden ob
rettungskräfte jetzt hier auch
teilbereiche ortsgrenze krankenhaus am
abend räumen müssen was natürlich ein
riesiger logistischer einsatz für die
einsatzkräfte sein wird
gerd weiß man irgendetwas über die
hintergründe gibt es forderungen
nein die polizei hat bisher noch keine
auskünfte gegeben darüber was genau
gedroht worden ist ob über telefon
gedroht wurde oder andersweitig das ist
noch unklar im moment konzentriert sich
alles darum diese ganze situation so
schnell wie möglich aufzuklären daran
ständig situationen hier im krankenhaus
sehr angespannt ist es werden da die
intensiv patienten behandelt es sind
doch ob es vielleicht im gange und dann
ist so eine notwendigkeit einer
evakuierung natürlich eine eine
besondere maßnahme die auch vorbereitung
bedingt ich kann ganz kurz darüber
zeigen hier sind also sehr sehr viele
rettungswagen inzwischen angekommen die
sich jetzt hier in bereitstellung
stellen und jetzt wird im grunde
hintergrund entschieden was passiert
müssen kräfte müssen patienten aus dem
krankenhaus heraus geholt werden aber
wichtig ist erst mal der ganze bereich
ist gesichert die polizei hat den
bereich hier in den stadtsaal
großflächig abgesperrt man kommt da
überhaupt nicht mehr daran und jetzt
sind auch spezialkräfte im einsatz
die im endeffekt das gebäude durchsuchen
und auch im hintergrund natürlich
ermitteln was hinter dieser drogen genau
steckt wir sind die patienten dass es
diese drohung gibt dass sie da in einer
gefährlichen situation sich momentan auf
halten
ja man kann davon ausgehen dass wenn
draußen vor der haustür so viele
rettungskräfte auflaufen das durch
nachfragen gibt und es wird sicherlich
auch dann entsprechende vorbereitung im
krankenhaus geben nach priorisierung wer
zuerst so ein krankenhaus land verlassen
muss die feuerwehr und auch die
rettungskräfte hier in bremerhaven sind
gut vorbereitet denn erst mitte mai gab
es ja hier in bremerhaven ganz in der
nähe ja wirklich ein paar straßen
entfernt
lloyd gymnasium einen amoklauf durch
einen schützen der mit einer armbrust
auf eine mitarbeiterin dort geschossen
hat und dort waren ja auch viele schüler
stundenlang im gebäude die dann
hinterher auch etwas dienstlich
behandelt werden mussten und aufgrund
dieser maßnahmen ist man im grunde ein
großes szenario mit vier rettungskräfte
mit viel polizei und durchsuchungen von
gebäuden gerade ja geübt und zwar real
geübt und deswegen gehe ich davon aus
dass diese maßnahme hier sehr
professionell und sehr schnell
aufgearbeitet werden kann er ist
informationen aus bremerhaven nach einer
bombendrohung gegen das dortige
krankenhaus bremerhaven mit vielen dank
eric schröder
[Musik]